well first of all nine years what the
hell were you guys doing
what were we doing i was doing all sorts
of things enjoying our lives i'm just
doing extensive research yeah uh in
antarctica oh
for the s
for humanity
okay pretty sure that's a blatant lie
yeah i've been having a good time look
we've all had some our own music we've
all been doing other acting projects we
truly needed to take a little bit of a
break which has made coming back
together so much sweeter we couldn't be
more excited so i got my sailing license
that's what i got okay that was actually
true sailing all over did you really get
your stainless i did it's amazing yeah i
love that at least yours you told the
truth exactly i told the truth i told
the truth i don't know what you're
talking about also where is your fourth
member nine years and we only got three
out of four in a sailing he bought a big
boat
this is true as well and he's in miami
right now working on it hey guys let me
out of here no this isn't there nope
don't have to do this
it's getting worse and
hey guys so happy to be here with the
boys i can't wait for
all of the awards
well he's a shorty because he's a little
bit shorter yes um well actually really
was to get down here
about that it's feeling personal it's
feeling personal
carl said that joke i'm with you i don't
know how i feel about that but it's fine
um no i'm a shortage you know how we
feel about it it's really not yet i'm
i'm a shorty i'm a show so wait so nine
years three out of four of you were here
i'm still gonna harass you guys for that
were you guys friends during the nine
years or was there beef i just want to
know in between everything yeah there
was always
were you friends with the fourth one
that's not here yes
she is trying to create yes
absolutely in fact he's had the best
place we go and visit his house in maui
all the time although i've got some
great stories there was one time on tour
one of the last tours that uh i ate one
of the sandwiches and then we got into a
fight and i tried to choke them out so
straight up you know there's always good
things
that happen yeah that's like brotherly
mom you were scared yeah i could see
that he was too i could see that i could
see that yeah so jlo is being honored
tonight
i love harassing you guys
jayla was being honored tonight do you
have an iconic jlo moment in your head
that just comes to you right away
i mean uh the dress
the green one the green dress okay
versace green i mean that's just the
first thing that popped up
the music video for love don't cost a
thing like that was on repeat like damn
loved it
i just i got to see her in concert in
vegas a few years back and i always
think about her performances there you
know just thinking oh what's this going
to be like in every single song she
hasn't lost a step she sounds great and
james knows all the lyrics to every song
so a big jayla fan what can i say it's
crazy
this is your moment she's probably
watching she's watching this yeah so let
me tell her how you feel you're a rock
you always have been and we're so happy
for you
for real this is you so he's stumbling
on his words
together
we're going to put a poster on our tour
bus door for motivation absolutely is
that okay to say you know i mean it in a
motivational way we're going to let's
run
something we wrap this up great awesome
thank you guys you guys are so fun i
love harassing you guys it was great
well it's great
yes dress
thank you well thank you thank you
it was
you guys have fun